first indication that's me the lines and
squares in this image make little sense
but they could hold a key to developing
the world's first coronavirus facts
professor Robin Shattuck and his small
team here in West London are in a global
race to find an inoculation against the
potentially fatal virus they've had one
major breakthrough already they're
nearly at the clinical trial stage to
get here would normally take two to
three years they've done it in 14 days
we'll have it in animal models by the
beginning of next week so we've kind of
short track that part the next phase
will be to move that from early animal
testing into first in human studies and
we think with adequate funding we can do
that in a period of a few months the UK
has pledged 20 million pounds to sepi
the Coalition for epidemic preparedness
innovations an international agency set
up in 2017 to deal with health crises
exactly like this one and a further 20
million pounds for rapid research into
coronavirus here in the UK the money is
crucial but so too is knowledge the 2003
SARS epidemic killed some 800 people at
the time China was severely criticised
for withholding information this time
it's been praised for sharing crucial
data with the international health
community the lessons learned following
the 2003 SARS outbreak are proving
crucial in helping scientists deal with
this epidemic but the SARS vaccine was
never fully developed once the virus
died out the funding dried up dr. David
Heyman is one of the world's leading
experts on infectious diseases he led
the international fight against SARS and
told me this time a vaccine must be
developed today we have a new coalition
the coalition on an epidemic
preparedness and innovation which is
based here in London which is
stimulating development of vaccines
and hopefully that will continue to
stimulate development of corona vaccines
after this outbreak is over it may not
be effective in getting a vaccine for
this outbreak a vaccine may not even be
necessary but it would be nice to have a
corona virus vaccine somewhere on the
shelf
it could be rolled out during a future
epidemic the corona virus is still
spreading fast it's possible it could
die off eventually but it's also true
that it has the potential to become a
pandemic Marcia's Joshi Sky News